必殺隊のトップぶを怒らせてしまい無限に放り込まれたサイコバスタ次郎。一体どうなるのか。さん
おお。
動けるか?動けなくても気合いで動け。
どうしたんですか、勇さん。どうしたんですか、勇さん?俺は怒っている。猛烈に背中と足と腕とかで頭と顔が痛いからだ。おかげで朝が発言してよかったじゃないですか。あざすって。俺はお前が嫌いだから話しかけるな。あ、
[音楽]
上だ。
カラス、バーガラス。
落ちる瞬間電波がなくなることを予想して先にユマーカラスを頼んでおきました。ゆさんザルツも早食い対決しませんか?
なんで
うど派ですか?ラーメン派ですか?メンヘラですか?
喋りかけるな。
こいつら当期がまるでない。扉を開けるまで気づかなかった。
関係ないけどそばそ多いですね。
黙れ。
久しいなあ。
あ、赤さんもそば食べますか?余の麺を他人に食わせるだ。
じゃあ審判お願いします。
え、
さあ始めようか。宴の時間だ。水の呼吸、死の型。ゲロゲロ。
うえー。
炭治郎の勝利。次はお前だ。
このおば練り上げられている。思考の領域に近いなつって。
こいつ強い。なんでこんなに余裕なんだ。
トイレ逃げるな。今
誰が入っている?
鬼に名乗るような名は持ち合わせていない。
早く交代しろ。余の便器に他人を座らせるな。
早く出ないとお前の脳水をぶち上げてやる。うわ。
俺が出るまでよく来られた。あとは任せろ、ベンザ。
[音楽]
う、俺はうんこをぶち負けるような弱者は嫌いだ。
うあ。
初めましてだね。炭治郎。
この秒弱抜けじ記憶喪失でもしたのか。この姿で会うのは初めましてだね。
炭治郎を倒すにはもっと力が必要だ。
あのお方の地だ。一滴も無駄にするなよ。ち
[笑い]
月10日。1月10
日はカラジオのライブイベントがやります。
こちらのQR
コードからみんな申し込んでね。ちちちちち
何とも修悪な姿だな。ク屋敷。私は永遠が何かを知っている。永遠とはすなわち死の世界だ。キ
ウブしきポン。
炭治郎、お前鬼だったのか?私の名前は胡蝶ちょのブ。姉を殺した鬼を探しているデブ。いや、ぽっちゃり系よ。飯の匂いがする。
[音楽]
いやいや、初めまして。俺の名前はどま?いい原ね。
この箱に見覚えはないか?
味噌。
もしもし。大丈夫ですか?
しのぶ、あなたは鬼殺さよ。
どんな鬼なの?どいつが味噌キを食ったの?頭からケチャップをかぶったような鬼だった。え?あ。
うわあ。動けるデブ。なんだね。なんで私のキ食べたの?ねえ。なんで?なんで食べたの?
あれは?
あー。
う、
カップ麺の食い方も知らねえのか。かすが西の呼吸だ。術破りが呼吸補吸冷たい。かき帰りみたいで美味しいです。
何
このフランスパンは大量のバターが練り込まれていて波底の消化しきれない。試しに親方様にあげたら寝込んでしまいました。どう?あ、
まだ消化できちゃった。ここまでは想定外です。
月術ルゲ術い手くり。お
帰術の白姫。
おお。
あれ、もうお腹いっぱいなの?いっぱい食べて速度も落ちてるし。食べることしか取りへのないデブが食えないでどうするんだよ。食べなさい。
[笑い]
食べれない。
お腹がパンパンに膨れ上がって息もできないの。
関係ありません。食べなさい。飯柱しのブー。私の味噌よ。
よくも食べたな。
とどめだ。
激術水レボスの呼吸ごの前爆色
ドボロおい腹を満たして逆にピロを上げたくら
ええ、さよなら。の補給死の方。
[笑い]
[音楽]
吸収してる最中に切りかからないでよ。
ああ、あれなんだこれ?もし味噌を奪った鬼と遭遇し、
2人で戦うことができたなら、第
の条件として私は鬼に食べられて死ななければなりません。
さようなら。
そのためにこの1
年大量のご飯を食べてきました。現在の私の体重は
97kg。
私を食べたら鬼は芋たで動けなくなるでしょう。
さよなら。
たは
[笑い]
さよなら。
あ、やっと死にました。よかった。
ねえ、しのぶーちゃん、俺と一緒にスイパラ行かない?
[音楽]
とっととまる豚野郎。
やべやろ。お前だろ。
次は何のサイコバスシリーズが見たい?
コメントで教えてね。